hello reject nation my name is Greg Alba
what is your name John ah it's probably
Greg Alva
well Greg Alba and I are gonna go watch
this video from whoa whoa calm top 10
male actors with iconic voices one of
our patreon reward tiers is whatever you
request we must definitely do whether it
be a video discussion or or a reaction
which is most likely what you will
request because it's us we have to do it
we are your reacting monkeys this was
sent over to us by none other than
Andrew Hayes and I want to make this
clear really quick Andrew Hayes has a
movie review YouTube channel and I'm
telling you this guy is very good at
reviewing movies I am NOT just saying
that I am saying that because it is true
so go check it out and tell you what
Andrew there's gonna be a link in the
description box he's very good about it
and when you're in California you're
gonna come on this channel Greg
shut up I'm sorry let's watch this bet
you Morgan Freeman and Schwarzenegger
[Music]
welcome to watchmojo.com Christopher
Walken for this little we're looking at
those male celebrity voices are just
about as notable face plasma rifle man
what do you want range it's just what
you see pal why would they present the
wisdom of a thousand sages or like
they're ordering a raid on the
neighboring village we can recognize
them instantly you may need other
people's lunches stop it
here's a man who likes a little volume
with his monologue
that his voice has evolved over the
course of his career as has his penchant
for yelling and most of his performances
do not they were complaining there's
really only one way to give a photo
facial speech to your double spawn or to
declare your intentions while holding an
automatic firearm why because I never
rejected him in spite of all his
imperfections I'm a fan of it
number 9 Arnold Schwarzenegger he's the
Austrian brick house with a voice that
won't quit lying from the Terminator as
memorable as it is and let's not forget
how much his accent lends itself to
awesome movie moments who is your daddy
and what does he do who doesn't like to
see former bodybuilders yelling about
tumors with a bunch of kindergarteners
we love it it's not a tumor it's not a
tumor
Urmi irons what do you want me to say
I'm sorry I'm saying tow life yes
his voice epitomizes that of the
distinguished English gentleman and
given his classical training in
Shakespeare it's probably not that far
from the truth accolades largely a
matter of nerve while he may make us
want to bust out some Earl Grey let's
not forget
[Laughter]
[Music]
you may remember him from when he and
some German friends tried to take over
Nakatomi Plaza in diehard tried my
admittance baby from when he kind of
wanted to kill Harry Potter but not
really you don't even know you are a
stupid girl he also managed to put that
British baritone to good use as a
crotchety caterpillar in Tim Burton's
Alice in Wonderland Roger who could play
it disaffected hookah smoking larval
insects better I'm Alice Casey Alice
they were just as differently to the
first time you hear you called it
Wonderland
number six hahaha rock on
Michael Jackson knew what was up when he
had him to do the voiceover for thriller
like the poem was written for him
and he was born to read it definitely
creepy delivery that he saw my wife
Lenore within these worlds
is it true sir have you her soul embody
his is a voice that could lure you
quietly to your death while you're too
busy being captivated by the coolness
it's like a goth siren song
when the voice that is evolved over the
years there's no mistaking this old
cowboy means business maybe who's
perpetually furrowed brow can help you
out
see in this world has two kinds of
people my friend put that shirt on
pretty clear one has the office he was
your mom's and or grandma's favorite sex
symbol
didn't have to be cut back it's easy to
see why with a decidedly Scottish lip it
is both charming and enviable
suspenseful west edges if a glass of
whiskey could talk he probably sound
like this guy and we'd be fine with it
except when he's trying to bark out
orders on a Russian submarine new policy
[Music]
yeah or maybe it's the Queens New York
did you talk to him something enjoyably
creepy about his vocal delivery Eddie
for friends have some pride in yourself
have some faith in Jesus Christ is your
number cute James Earl Jones gotta
satisfy the Star Wars fans there was
gonna be Morgan Freeman I feel like it's
hard to ignore he's voiced one of film's
greatest villains as well as one of his
greatest line that alone that he didn't
speak whatsoever
to know that Stallone has to be an
honorable mention Keith David yo
but if you don't I will look for you I
will find you
I got a level 1 radiation leak every
surface of the ship is contaminated
[Music]
windiest and coldest march of the
Penguins
forever has defined it done okay pretty
much so in some ways this is a story of
survival somewhere between the Shawshank
Redemption and march of the Penguins he
became the de facto would go to war
narration there must be a con like me
and every prison in America I'm the guy
who can get it for you
cigarettes America refund if that's your
thing
a bomb abandon to celebrate two kids
high school graduation there anything
within reason is pleasant soothing voice
as a paternal quality that's a great
very easy to get lost any storyteller
given it's a voice that can rock you to
sleep and also work out the details of a
horrific car accident without missing a
beat prison time is slow time so you do
what you can to keep going some fellows
collect stamps others milled immensity
houses it's a quality that's hard to
find in most people let alone most
actors but it's more than that really
this is the story about love do you
agree with our list
what male actor do you think has the
most iconic men in my heart
I feel like Keanu Reeves can be on there
Keanu Reeves could be on there I think
Keith David should have been the
honorable mentions to be honest I mean
Keith David has such a unique voice and
has done so much voiceover work that you
know over the years he used to be like
the voice of the Army and the BMW
commercials and stuff is surprisingly a
lot of famous actors out there who don't
really have iconic voices Gilbert
Godfried man where was he
be fair that is a very unique frequently
referenced it's funny how like Brad Pitt
and Tom Cruise don't really have voices
that if you heard them really that's
definitely yeah you can pick up you
could pick up on it it's not as easily
identifiable but yet they're like
superstars it's Albert yeah Mark
Wahlberg's got a pretty distinct voice
part of what makes Mark Wahlberg's voice
so distinct now is Andy samberg's
impression yeah because when he started
doing that it really like tapped into
the oh that's what it is
how Pacino yeah yeah pretty like to be
in the devil's advocate a couple years
ago I went to New York City oh I had
never been to a Broadway play my life I
find out Pacino starring in a Broadway
play one of my all-time faves so I said
you know what that's how I introduced
myself to Broadway it's been a [ __ ] ton
of money on these tickets I go there
browse the bottom floor and I was to the
far left and apparently Broadway seats
are so tiny there's just like three or
four pound guy who's half of his body
was leaning over on the other side of my
armrest like here so he was like I'm
fading my chair oh like a lot it was
like annoying little like your arm out
of the way it's like his body is
literally here that's so what do you do
situation and he falls asleep and start
snoring cuz this plays freaking boring
this Pacino's is yelling nonsense the
entire time and I left halfway through
sorry
an enjoyable experience I have me back
to Broadway
Pacino so funny you know you used to be
like all Day Afternoon Sal what are you
doing Sal now he's like Batman of course
Arnold yeah that's a great coffee
caramel should be higher yeah everyone
knows Arnold and that's an impression
everybody does to you I feel like yeah
it's a little weird for Arnold to be
number 9 his voice is so distinct partly
because of his accent yeah this is
because I guess I fired your iconic
voice I would also think like what are
the most impersonal voices and like
Arnold's alone Pacino walking I wonder
if they maybe put that at number 9 to
like put a big recognizable one you know
close to first you know like one of the
huge ones you don't maybe lead with
walkins but yeah you can lead with
Arnold Jeremy Irons beautiful beautiful
voice yeah Jeremy Irons is just don't
trust he seems like an untrustworthy guy
in real life you don't trust your vibes
ever in the room you know I would I
would look around you know make sure I
know we're there I wouldn't be like I
appreciate your work I'd be like I don't
trust you pal do you really have Bruce
Wayne's best interests at heart today
because he's so good at playing
deceitful bad guys yeah why Jeff
Goldblum Jeff Goldblum Jeff Goldblum
yeah I mean that's the and that's a
distinctive asset it's hard to ever sit
yeah but people do it it's good oh man
I'm surprised if golems on on here he's
a famous one Alan Rickman of course man
he's that's that's a beautiful voice
right there yeah rest in peace I'm
surprised they didn't pull the Family
Guy the Family Guy answer yeah a bit
because that's part of what really shows
culturally speaking yeah that dude has a
distinct voice yeah Alan Arkin has a
pretty distinct voice too
yeah good call good call Alan Rickman I
heard he was actually just a super sweet
guy in real life it was crazy he's kind
of typecast into being more of mean or
bad guys or mean or cold early guys and
even though he doesn't play a super
faithful dude in love actually he's a
much sweeter hearted guy in that movie
when he's more of like a rig
you'll agree on character yeah and I was
she ate when he was around that he was
able to play more of those kind of roles
although if he was strolling around I
would have liked to have had him scold
me at least one time you know if you
just like spill something on his shoes
yeah that you can you know he won't yell
at you but he will tell you everything
that's wrong with you and what led to
this terrible decision of spilling it's
classic it's a price man he Vinnie P
dude and Vinnie P he's your man yeah man
Vincent Price definitely has an iconic
voice that has endured Clint Eastwood's
considered this like amazing film
director yeah he always plays the same
rough rough tough as nails guy gruff guy
whose arc is that he eventually learns
to open up a little bit
demonstrates some compassion in a way
that people in his life can kind of tell
it's there I wonder what I'm sure it's
very different than what the characters
are that he portrays I feel like he has
this gruff persona however just if I'm
if I'm just imagining the microcosm of a
set that he's directing I imagine he
probably runs a pretty Pleasant set I
just get that vibe I heard he treats his
actors like horses that's what Tom Hanks
said interesting yeah you really cheap
that he chooses actors like he's very
kind he doesn't even say action he's
like I prefer action I want you to say
the line now repeated Sean Connery Sean
Connery I've been revisiting actually
there's some I've just been visiting for
the first time
old Bond movies man no one did it like
him no no his voice is so iconic that he
was able to play like Russians and
Spaniards without ever even having to
change it or do it at all just a lot of
Jackson comes
in bond it does it comes out all yeah
you can't fully change his accent come
from Spain
make sure you did now when he was bond
it's just shock when you see that that
body shot that would be the before photo
yeah daniel craig is bond or any other
action role man you got to have like an
eighteen pack and like four packs you
got to be like a bulk order of you're
gonna have like six different biceps you
have to become a bodybuilder in your
spare time yeah back then i'm like no
one had it like him because he just
carried himself it was the performance
man john connor and that voice so iconic
I wish it would come back well you're in
luck man he made an animated motion
picture in Scotland a couple of years
ago check that out all voice maybe
impressed I'm waiting to be impressed
I'm working to be impressive here it
again that's League of Extraordinary
Gentlemen yeah hands down the best
Connery Oh Seven Psychopaths everyone
has a Walken impression hello cow about
now seven psycho to Mai's fell into a
bucket of cream what did Danny's got a
grand slam hey you know I'm just a
little bummed that they decided to ruin
the fight his character Seven
Psychopaths mine is like halfway I try
to I try to get the gruff like valleys
yeah I do the very oh there are two
kinds of Christopher Walken
impersonations and that's how you know
he's got my conic voice partly because
there's the cartoon one everyone can do
similar with Arnold and then there's the
actual impression armed and walking are
far off try to mix them are you doing
why are you doing see now it just sounds
like I hidden this watch am i to you
[ __ ] wristwatch James Earl Jones oh
yeah yes he has an iconic
absolutely on this list but something
tells me watch mojo put them on number
two to satisfy Star Wars fans which is
okay I don't think it's as iconic he's
got like I feel like what Bader is very
iconic I mean in terms of like his
performance history I guess the thing
that you think about for his voice is
Darth Vader
I think of Field of Dreams cuz I've seen
it a bunch of times maybe his
filmography isn't quite as indicative of
this like not all of his roles make a
point to utilize his voice but I think
his voice is super iconic and he was the
voice of CNN but is it number two I
don't know I think there's a good
argument for it because again he just
lucked out with getting that rich deep
he didn't look out man I mean Morgan
Freeman deserves to be number one you
know why cuz that's his built that voice
it kind of did that's is not as natural
speaking voice it's a whole interview
with him on it I forget where he's from
things from like South or something or
Mississippi I forget where he's from but
he had a very different voice and then
when he was going to theater he had to
train his voice to speak and pronounce a
certain way and it naturally became his
speaking voice over time he just trained
it to develop its weight so with knowing
them you know what you had to like
developed your voice yes oh good for you
Morgan Freeman and yeah he's the master
of narration oh yeah and he's God God
there's a reason I was not either
surprised or upset that he yeah because
he is the voice the voice he should
audition for the voice he'd probably win
by just speaking oh yeah this was a good
list we had a Sofia of our own so we
mentioned throughout this video anyway
thanks Andrew Hayes for the
recommendation you can subscribe to
watchmojo.com bell follow us on social
media and please follow us on the
stardust app we are part of the Stardust
community now shall we are so many big
youtubers on there but if this is your
first time hearing about it go to this
unique URL link in the description box
download the app and follow us first
yeah okay they need to know yeah we were
the first ones to sign you and send us
your thor ragnarok reactions tag us and
tech startup oh yeah okay this is 30
second reactions for any film TV show or
trailer by the way I'm not
review every episode of the flash but I
will give you my instant thoughts on
every episode over there see how that
works